هنا في بخمه الاوكرانيه تقترب اطول واشرس
معركه في الحرب من نهايتها حيث تقول
المعلومات والصور القادمه من هناك ان
الخناق يضيق على المقاومين الاوكران ضيق
يقابله اصرار على الصمود حتى النهايه
المدينه الصغيره بحجمها الكبيره في اسمها
وموقعها الاستراتيجي اصبحت ايقونه في
الحرب الدائره منذ عام ورمزيه للانتصار
لمن يسيطر عليها بعد اشهر من الجمود على
طول الجبهات المشتعله شرقا وجنوبا
تعتبر بخموت اخر القلاع الاوكرانيه في
اقليم دونيتسك شرقي اوكرانيا وهدفا رئيسيا
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حيث سيمنح
الاستيلاء عليها موسكو انتصارا نادرا بعد
عده اشهر من النكسات موقع المدينه يشكل
نقطه التقاء استراتيجيه بين منطقتي
الدوناتين تشكلان القلب الصناعي الاوكراني
اضافه لكونها تعتبر نقطه انطلاق جديده
للجيش الروسي باتجاه العمق الاوكراني
واكبر مدينتين في المنطقه هما كراماتورس
كوسوفيانس تقول اخر المعلومات ان قوات
فاجنر دخلت احياء باخموت الشرقيه والوسطى
فيما تزال الاحياء الشماليه بيد الجيش
الاوكراني لتتحول المعركه الى حرب شوارع
بين الطرفين
لم تنفي صعوبه الوضع في المدينه شبه
المحاصره لكنها تصر وجيشها على الصمود رغم
شراسه المعارك وموقفها المعقد
يمكن للجميع ان يرى اننا نواجه صعوبه في
هذا القسم الامامي العدو يهاجم باستمرار
في مجموعات صغيره وكبيره فاحيانا يوصلون
القصف المدفعي واليوم التالي يشنون هجمات
المشاه انه امر صعب لكن اولادنا يستمرون
في الصمود بارضهم
بين تراقب سقوط وقدره على الصمود فالاكيد
ان القتال في باخمت اصبح معركه كسر عظم
بين الطرفين معركه قد تكون انعطافه جديده
لحرب بدات لتوها عامها الثاني